[Music]
on the 22nd of september 2020
tesla had their annual meeting of
stockholders and battery day
during the session tesla ceo elon musk
an svp for powertrain and energy
engineering at tesla drew baglino both
made a series of very crucial
announcements about the future of the
company
one of those announcements was the new
battery cell that they are developing
that would change the electric vehicle
industry
forever in fact this battery is so
important that it's going to make
electric vehicles from tesla
as cheap as 25 000 the audience of cars
cheered with their horns as they
welcomed the new car that would dethrone
them
it felt like something from cars but how
come a single innovation on their car
batteries is going to change the cost of
the entire
vehicle as well as its performance well
in this video we're going to see why the
4680 tablet battery
is such a game changer and what's a
better place to start than at the
beginning
but first welcome back to our channel if
you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe
button and ring that bell so you're
notified every time we upload a new
video
great now where were we ah yes at the
beginning
you see electric vehicles or evs have
always existed
in fact in the late 19th century and
early 20th century there were just as
many as internal combustion engine cars
or
ices being driven around however they
faced several issues concerning the
range and charging eventually
with the advent of the electrical
igniting device for gas engines coupled
with the mass production of ice vehicles
using henry ford's novel assembly line
evs would see a massive decline in
production and use
ices hit higher speeds had more range
and did not require frequent charging
due to a higher specific energy or
energy density
this energy density is the amount of
energy that a unit of mass or volume in
a particular system will produce
the new 4680 batteries will produce five
times more energy than its predecessor
the 2170.
you see the names of these batteries are
actually their dimensions
the 2170 has a 21 millimeter diameter
and a 70 millimeter length while the
4680 has a 46 millimeter diameter and an
80 millimeter length
so of course the 4680 has more energy
with its bigger dimensions
but it's not just about size it's about
what you can do with it
you see both ices and evs make use of
batteries
however while ices make use of their
batteries to ignite the car engine and
run things like the music
evs make use of their batteries to run
everything including the movement of the
vehicle itself
this has required a lot of technological
ingenuity over the years
let us take a look at a battery cell a
typical battery cell makes use of
electrodes and an electrolyte
a battery has two electrodes the
positive terminal called the cathode
and the negative terminal called the
anode the electrodes react with the
electrolyte to give off some electrons
through the anode
these electrons are then channeled
through a circuit till they get back to
the cell through the electron deficient
cathode
you see what we do with batteries is to
move electrons from one point to another
while making the electrons do work for
us as they travel in ice vehicles the
electric current passes through the
alternator to start the engine in
electric vehicles
it passes through an induction motor the
battery is more powerful depending on
the mass of the battery's components
the type of connection and the type of
anode and cathode material being used
the 4680 is obviously bigger so there's
that
as for the connection battery cells can
be connected in either a parallel or a
series
connecting batteries in parallel
increases the current or capacity
while connecting the batteries in series
increases the voltage
the tesla model 3 for example makes use
of the 2170 battery cell which has a
3.65 voltage and a capacity of 4
000 milliamp hours the model 3 is fitted
with over 4 000 of these cells using
both parallel and series connections to
increase both the overall voltage and
capacity
this results in an energy density of 150
kilowatt hours per kilogram and a range
of 310 miles
which is pretty great this is standard
tesla practice so we can expect to see
the same connections for cars with the
tablet batteries
when it comes to the anode and cathode
materials the 4680 uses lithium-based
compounds for its cathode while the
anode is going to be silicon instead of
the graphite that is more common in
other tesla batteries
the company decided to make the choice
to remove cobalt from its batteries as
its production has some questionable
processes
however these new additions and
subtractions in the battery's
constituents
actually reduce the cost for making the
battery while being more efficient
subsequently the dollar per kilowatt
hour for 46.80
is lower than that for the 2170 battery
another cost reducing step is the
implementation of a dry coating process
for the cathodes instead of the wet
process
the dry process would not require the
amount of solvent and machinery used in
the wet process
thereby cutting down factory space
drastically while making the process
more environmentally friendly while
eliminating waste water
but perhaps the most important addition
is the tablets feature
or should i say the most important
subtraction as tesla has engineered
their batteries to move from having a
tab
to well not having a tab the tab is a
metallic strip placed on the anode and
cathode to direct the flow of electrons
with one strip each on an electrode
the electrodes have to travel a long
distance from one strip to another
this long distance creates resistance
and power loss which in turn causes
overheating leading to tesla
incorporating glycol casings in the
battery packs to cool down the system
but let us look at the tablet's design
first off let's start by establishing
the fact that the 4680 is not
tables before the anode cathode and
separator are rolled into a sheet
they are actually fitted with several of
these tabs but in such a manner that the
tabs overlap
when the entire thing is rolled up into
the jelly roll it looks like this
the result is that the electrons have a
far shorter distance to cover
there is less resistance and a drastic
reduction in power loss as well
this of course solves the overheating
problem and will make charging the
battery much faster
it is expected to get a full charge
within 10 minutes using a supercharger
and since it has five times more energy
six times more power and will increase
range by 16
we can expect to be seeing way less
charging times than we're seeing in any
evs today
and it's all because of the tablets
rather the tab full design
however tesla is also taking advantage
of the size of these batteries
size is not all that matters but bigger
is usually better you know
and mr musk knows this full well that is
why moving forward
they've decided to make use of the
batteries for the structure of the cars
as well
instead of being inside cases at the
bottom of the car the bottom of the car
itself
is the case for the battery packs this
helps reduce the parts involved in the
car as tesla plans to implement a giga
casting machine to build the single
biggest cast for an automobile to
implement these designs
so let's look at the overall effect of
the 4680 tablets tesla battery
first it has more energy power and range
meanwhile
the production process which will be
done by tesla themselves is cheaper
requires less factory space and is more
eco-friendly the battery also adds to
the integrity of the car as the new
structure plus the low center of gravity
of tesla cars make their cars nyon
impossible to topple over
all this and more with the lower dollar
per kilowatt hour this makes it clear
why tesla can talk about a 25 000
vehicle with these batteries
see the battery packs constitute about a
quarter of the car's weight and cost
so a reduction in the cost of the
battery will also mean a reduction in
the price of the car
coupled with other innovations tesla
will incorporate into their cars
musk has stated that a full integration
of this battery in cheaper evs at a good
scale will be available in three years
from now
that was almost a year ago and when a 25
electric vehicle becomes available
there'll be almost no need for people to
buy ice vehicles
since in addition to the fact that they
are cheaper to have all of the other
constraints we talked of earlier will
then be eliminated
range will increase dramatically
charging will be easier
faster and last longer and evs will cost
just as much as ices
reversing the impact of henry ford's
assembly line innovation centuries ago
electric vehicles will be the most used
cars carbon emissions will be
drastically reduced
and psychopaths will have no excuse for
having jumper cables in their vehicle
and it'll all be because of this
magnificent innovation the tablets 4680
battery
but what do you think is the tablet's
4680 battery on the same level as the
invention of the assembly line
how much effect do you think it will
have on society let us know in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video
make sure to give it a like and check
out other awesome ones on the simply
tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time